good evening everybody welcome to the
meeting of the audit committee first
thing to do is the emergency evacuation
announcement the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
there is one fire exit in this room if
you need to evacuate the moon do so by
the glass floor to the external fire
escape escape staircase
please hold both handrails in case of
stairs of well slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they please
allow others to exit the room before
they go to the fire escape door where
they can then be given systems the
70-point will be in the public car park
at the side of the Civic suite please
don't delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff please note this
meeting will be audio recorded and can I
please remind you to switch off your
mobile phones of odd challenge silent
thank you alright
item one apologies for absence we've
really saved apologies from councillor
meal
councillor Newport mrs. Shaw and mr. P
Shaw substitute members so we've got
councillor Gooding welcome and council
alumna welcome
thank you and you know members attending
no I told for the minutes of the meeting
held on the 26th of November 2019 which
is last week wasn't it
we've all read them do we agree them
really great yes five five
I can tribe to receive declarations of
interest other name item six financial
statements 2018 19 and that's to
consider the report of assistant
director resources presenting the
audited accounts for 2018-19
for members of the accounts and then I
will let me Hanson who's the audit
partner anyway and so I would I'll take
you through the covering report and then
I will just sort of point you in the
direction of a couple of the changes
that we've made since the report was
circulated and the handouts I've just
given to servants aware of what papers
they've got in front of them so the
report that was circulated on Tuesdays
x-alps II was preliminary and audit
conclusion in relation to the audit of
our accounts for 1819 as up this as of
today's date that only way has
substantially concludes it's actually
completed their audit work however
they're asked in a few outstanding
issues and that need to be resolved and
those are listed in in the audit report
and we will go through which and
commitment areas of work still needs and
some resolutions and enforcedly
meeting however at this point in time
they are expecting to wish us with an
unqualified audit opinion and also a
positive value for money conclusion in
which means they've got no it matters
too important in terms of the way of the
economy efficiency and effectiveness in
which we use our resources our counsel
so that's that's a positive news story
for the council so just to give a little
bit of context then this is the second
year which we've worked to the only
reporting deadline of the 31st of May's
which means that we had to publish our
draft set of accounts full of updates
and in previous years we've had to work
to a date of 31st of July which is to
two months later so obviously you are
working within impedance and timeframe
there is a statutory obligation on the
council to then either publish the final
set of audited accounts by the 31st of
July which is the deadline that we all
tend to work to or if that's not
possible which has been the case for us
this year to publish a statement on our
website to say what why wouldn't quite
an order to two counts on all available
at that point in time so from the
council point perspective we have
complied of our statutory obligation and
we published the notice on the website
before the end of July to say that the
final version of the accounts and had
not been for the audited at that stage
and the reason why which again will
touch on a bit and dispute to resourcing
pressure divinity why which meant they
weren't fully able to complete the
testing by that 50.1 so we are as a
result of the fact that the auditors
were like substantially complete it's
not quite complete at this stage we are
asking the committee to delegate the
final approval of the set of accounts to
the chair or the Audit Committee
secants in a butcher in conjunction with
myself after this committee date because
we're not expecting any material changes
now to the version of the accounts which
we have circulated tonight on which we
will obviously be sending an updated
link to yourselves to review as well
obviously we are aware that that is
developed so generally of speaking audit
committee as a committee is asked to
approve the set of accounts but because
they're not quite finished at this point
of time we are asking for the delegation
to the chair of the Audit Committee but
obviously this is an opportunity for you
tonight to ask any questions and make
sure you're comfortable and with that
approach and we obviously try not so
many questions to the best of our
ability in terms of the information
that's been presented to you tonight but
as I say we're not expecting any
material substantive changes to happen
to the version which has now been
circulated to yourself so in terms of
the information that we have now updated
since the version that was sent out on
Tuesday there are two pages where we've
made some adjustments so page 21 which
details
bordick differences so things where
we've chosen to adjust accounts or
things that are being found during the
course of the audit work so going will
take me to take these with us during the
meeting and then secondly page 45 which
is the outstanding muscle to be still
resolved and we've updated the progress
in terms of those those items and we
have made analysis and further progress
since the report was circulated so again
we will update you on the latest edition
in terms of that and as I said finally
we've now tabled a set of updated
accounts which reflects all the
adjustments which are detailed in in the
reports so that we'll need a final sort
of review in check before we publish and
the final final version on the council's
website so yeah that's the position of
where we are at the moment and I'm
probably at this point and over we don't
need to take you through the draft
so it takes through the audit reports
and then we can point you to actually
any changes within the accounts so we
have that we have made since the draft
version so I'm conscious that members
probably haven't got very long to read
this report so whatever we proposed to
do is to take you through probably a
little bit more detail and I normally
wouldn't just take you through the key
areas not not every page of the report
I'm sure you'll be cut to know but what
we think of the key issues so the the
only change regarding the scope fold in
reality when we do our planning with sex
it based on rush years accounts
obviously once we get the draft
financial sense we revisit that
materiality and that's resulting in a
very small change in our material
exactly which is reported in that scope
change the next section refers the
status of the order as knowing there's
no assembly substantially confident to
deal with it and Chris for later on take
you through the authentic appendix which
just highlights the areas of work that
we're still working on they are not
really significant areas a lot of those
areas are in review which means that
either Chris or myself needs to just
review but the work has been completed
but until that with new processes
fine lies we obviously can't say that
the work is fully that completes I think
at that point is appropriate as well -
thank you very much the finals team for
varied Wizards I think during this audit
which is from my perspective not being
able to smoothest as low as said the
issues the delay of the audits day to
our resourcing issues there are no
reflection on the aid of the council's
financial states themselves or the
councillors finance team and I think
it's important to make that clear to the
committee is because leaving club
appropriate resources to the right
skills to complete bills at a mutually
prime time frames and therefore that
audit is expended to make sure we can
still deliver the quality audit and the
assurance that this committee needs to
receive regarding the financial
statements so again thank you to the
finance team for bearing with us our
thinking and what's been not an easy
process this year the next section
report is the only differences where we
have in the executive summary fair today
they will have more detail on those in
section 4 so rather than go through
those now propose to take through the
updated section 4 which has been
circulated to you if I can then take the
food is very briefly the next section
reports refers to on page 11 the areas
of audit Focus which I will go and take
you through an emergency because key
risks we identified on the audit in the
procedures we undertook to address those
risks and then the next section is
control observations we adopt what we
call the police
substantive approached premises accounts
which means we don't test the operation
of the controls and key financial
systems what we do instead is we test
individual transactions in detail so
income expenditure debtors creditors etc
pick transactions and test those back to
source however if we do identify what we
think of any control differences we do
we put those facts about the finance
team and yourselves as those charged
with governance and the only issue we
really picked software which is not
significant but we are highlighting it
is where we found some differences
between the ledger and the underlying
systems I think these are issues that
have been there for a number of year in
the [ __ ] years and the finance team were
aware of those and we'll be working on
improving those controls at the next
year and the final one which will be
changed with some evidence to support
the earing of debt collection and that
provision confirmation and again discuss
what the furnace team and then we can
make sure that we will run reports out
at the 31st of March to make sure that
the audit trail to support those
calculations next year value for money
is Naomi a second proposing to issue an
unqualified conclusion we did identify
their risk in relation to our work will
be made into the egg pencils after the
reprogram when the gang got more detail
further on the report which I just refer
you to the next section just refers to
the other responsibilities that we have
in terms of reporting duties and powers
and there's no no nothing that's we've
added about during the audit which is
resulting the need for us to exercise
any of those powers and we also have no
matter that reports or information to
the independence of the audit team so if
I can take you to text section to have
your reports so that just goes through
the main areas of focus missing
they identified the first risk we
identified what we call this dense juice
recorded error that's driven by the
auditing standard are supported and
therefore we identify that risk on every
sale engagements we the main procedure
to detect to address that risk is we
look at journals we also look at unusual
transactions in any areas where
management potentially to being
financial statements our Testament
journals is was not complete the data
production this report Criswell updates
as to whether that's been finalized now
but we haven't identified any issues
that identified any inappropriate
journals as part of our work and would
you identify any unusual transactions
the next significant miss we identified
again you will see in virtually all our
local authority building plans is the
incorrect capitalization of revenue
expenditure the reason we identified
that is because that's really the only
Road accounts where there's an incentive
for the council to lose things between
revenue and capital if you move things
out of the income expenditure accounts
and put it onto the balance needs
property plant and equipment it means
that X expenditure and Finance from
different sources therefore it means it
doesn't have impact on your council tax
lately so that's an area of potential
manipulation and it's also quite a
judgemental area sometimes in terms of
whether something is revenue or cap
itself therefore we identify that as a
risk and undertake additional testing on
all of the PP additions in the year to
make sure that not only have the
expenditure incurred but it is genuinely
capital in nature that's been included
in PPA again we did not identify any
issues as a result of that testing those
the only two significant risks we have
in relation to the orbit and other same
uses in pretty much all of our look at
our table
support the other areas we identified
our areas of focus so they're higher
inherent risk the first of those relates
to pension liability valuation which is
a very very big bigger bigger sorry and
the case is accounts are these subjects
estimation enrichment is provided by an
external expert informed by x-ray but we
still need to undertake procedures to
make sure that we can rely on that
expert to give you accurate figures
we've set out the report what we the
procedures we need to take so we lay the
blades with a pension fund auditor we
also engage our own actuaries to look at
the work of your factories and also
people you see as the consulting actuary
who's appointed by the NAO and we also
look at the movements in film asset
values between the actors estimates and
the actual year-end position the only
issue that was identified in relation to
pensions that she was a national issue
so it's again it's not an error in the
sense of the council having their
accounts it relates to a leak a couple
of legal rulings along with coaches
MacLeod and the other one guaranteed
minimum pensions which relate to Gemma's
of an age discrimination and other
discrimination cases the McLeod McClaren
ruling in late June early July so after
the Council of primaries accounts which
meant that the council or the actuary
was now able to estimate the impact of
McLeod previously have been disclosed
potentially contingent liability because
it was there wasn't sufficient certainty
around you and it wasn't therefore cut
possible to calculate an estimate the
ruling that basically said the
government can't appeal against the
previous judgment changed that and as a
result of the naturally Department said
it was possible factories to produce an
estimate of this figure
as a result of that the council obtained
an updated is 19 report for the accurate
reflects their movements and has updated
the financial statements to recognize
that additional liability well our own
procedures to check that we were
comfortable with that that estimates
again using information provided by our
actuaries and we're happy that that
estimate in terms of movement seemed
reasonable the next area we're always
identifies a no inherent risk is
valuation of property plant equipment
very similar reasons to pensions very
large figure based on estimates and
judgments again you do use and value as
to to prepare that information for you
we do quite a lot of work around PPE so
not only would you consider the work
undetected by the values but we also
test inputs to the valuations we look at
the judgments we checked the
calculations the only issue that we
noted was in relation to the indexation
and the depreciating replacement cost of
assets we're five percent index have
been used but it was just the date which
that have been applied was the wrong
date so that's never been corrected to
be applied from the correct date and
that resulted in increasing values of
london buildings of six hundred and
seventy six thousand the next two attack
to areas that we identified our first of
all grouper banks so green gate we're
limited we highlight because there's
always complexity in production of group
of accounts so we will check receivers
to make sure that the material and
accuracy of that consolidation and we
didn't identify any issues in relation
to that we then also noted as a
potential risk the restructuring of the
finance team and that was at the time of
developing our X line audit plan we
monitored proposals to restructure the
team and I think the
that actually kept produced on time we
found very few errors means that
actually that that wasn't IRISA
restructuring has gone very well and I
think hopefully you know would work very
well with carrying sensitive financial
statements the next two I'll skim over
fairly quickly it's basically new
accounting standards that applied in
2018-19 elation to finish instruments
and revenue from contracts with
customers we didn't expect even these
standards tala significant impact on the
most relevant Authority clients and we
were happy that the council would assess
those approach it and make changes where
they need to particular in relation to
just disclosures around financial
instruments so the next section report
just includes an example of our audit
report which as Carey's already noted
we're proposing a bit when qualifies and
I can't imagine anything on the care of
the next week that would change that
position and then the next section
report all the difference where you have
three new axes complex the very ones you
have in your papers yes that's correct
there's in the original version
circulators one page of users and to two
pages in those meetings and thirty two
terms of your big differences so Debbie
is talked about in terms of the a21
except the balance sheet
regarding the cloud London buildings but
valuations so the new ice understand
started with the cash
in investments and what this basically
means is that puts on me on the face of
the balance sheet there is cash and
having looked at the items that were in
there we saw some items there that were
over 90 to 90 days duration and I put to
the code that should really been fast as
the investments so there's been a change
on the face of the balance sheet to
change to move items outs with the cash
cash in cash business bigger into the
investments with 7.6 million and that's
just a last month moving the money
around to do propio calcification the
second item is to do is boom short-term
debtors have been shorter and creditors
these have been increased by two hundred
forty four thousand this was an item
actually found earlier in the audience
and just to make our way to Marsha's or
adjustments but that's why it on the on
the system now as showing increasing
dissatisfaction and finally there been
members to the cash flow statements of
the primary statement for to 28,000 as
results to McLeod judgment the 1.1
million is to do with a just a miss
mapping it of from the working papers to
the cash flow statement it's it doesn't
have an effect on the on the possible
either the council at always just look
it's just how the the figures back
through to the cash flow statement
itself and then one hundred and six
thousand pounds it in terms of Democrats
and comfortable creditors which were
where the final on counts were absolute
when they dropped account Russia
produced
no longer needed by the council but the
cash flow wasn't updated because those
items so the council has amended for
those they've had to go to the next next
page then the item on disclosure notes
hasn't changed but out the bottom there
is they're having court uncertainty and
what that insurgency is really is is to
do with respect to us some half a
million pounds and this is this is a sum
of score called developers body section
106 monies and these are monies held by
the council on behalf of the NH NHS
bodies and the what the position is here
is that the monies with with the council
is sitting it's directly directly
confirmed the money to the bank accounts
so it's been but it is he is not in
Rogers accounts and it doesn't seem to
be in the NHS account so in the
insurgency is just to see where these
these this money actually lies and it's
in a sort of position on this is that we
may we're still going to look at that
insensibly
how we deal with it but it's like to be
an item whereby we decide that it needs
to be resolved next year and it may be
an area but the council does not adjust
for it as it's not material and then
when you see that in a lot of
representation from from ourselves we
just doing some further work to to check
the position
how much was that just over 500,000
pounds I think the key thing to know to
these it is not that they do not
represent the funds that are available
for the council for its use they are
funds of it as an effective holding for
the NHS to use because the NHS can't
help those funds so it seems to be quite
a technical area that we may need to
raise to actually find out how should
that be treated and is it that it's
actually missing and is it occurring
elsewhere it might not be something
that's unique to Rockford we understand
the treatments the same as occurred in
the previous years but the sum is larger
this year I think is about 100,000 last
year before and so Mary I don't think we
could be a lovely voltage buffer capsule
to adjust and include in your cash
balance because it doesn't represent
usable forms of the council but there is
a question about where it has been
accounted for so I think we just like to
terminate it in this meeting and then
probably actually to include it in your
letter of representation included in the
schedule of uncertainties as Chris said
it's not material and if there is it
just risen quite a question which I
think the council's planning to take for
me to see assurances on we would also
check for there's an Aldi phone to see
if we can
this is occurring elsewhere and we
should be treated question I'm just
trying to understand exactly what you're
saying you're saying that you can't find
this half a million within the accounts
no no it's not in the accounts we know
it's in the cases bank account it's on
the bank statements the council knows
it's in their bank accounts but it is
not monies that the council can use for
any purpose so it would be I think
probably inappropriate for its big show
needs in that way but we what we don't
know is where it's actually showing in
terms of you know the whole it's pretty
much the word missing that's what it's
not missing not just tense it's time
sure where it should be be noted yeah
it's a not bank account we know who's
got the cash it's just it's not sure
okay
thank you so that's a few manage
relationship to those areas and I think
the other point to draw sorry sorry
sorry I'm just gonna ask for that half a
million is that just sitting in the
account or has it been invested
somewhere to earn some interest and
Perley agreements and we only have to
put it into a bank account where it
attracts interest rate similar to LIBOR
but the interest again is added on to
their balance so again we wouldn't
benefit from any of that okay and I
think just by way of context in terms of
building differences obviously McLeod is
an issue that's impacted on all the case
this year other than that I think
they're fairly minor issues I think just
to give the committee assurance that it
set for cats have been well prepared and
we generally find differences when we do
in order that's that's the nature of
audit as we go over it in a lot of
detail so I think overall the well
prepared set of accounts and relatively
few differences
if I can with the next section report
refers to valuable anyways so as I
highlight seed we identify waterways in
relation to councils access living
program we also assess the council's
fellow resilience so we look to the
budget meeting chair financial strategy
capital treasure management strategies
and we also looked at service
performance indicators particularly with
Google rather depends from IT families
in the year and we wanted to confirm
that those actors have in terms of we
highlighted here so again we're
comfortable with the arrangements in
place during year is a canary we'll
continue to look at so next year we're
looking again at the next stage of the
program which has obviously progressed
but our arrangements here is purely
looking at arrangements at the end of
March 2019 so we're not assessing
anything
since that day but we've been looking at
that next year when we do I value so
many conformation other reporting issues
it's not terribly interesting so I will
kind of take that was ready to leave the
responsibilities and other things that
we have to do and the other matters
section 7 just repeats the point about
controlled environment and everything
highlighted in the executive summary
section 8 on dexter element it's just
the quincies benefit issue i hope some
assurance that just cycles are some
areas look at the whole population the
PA you do that Ami's journals payroll
and so rather than just texas there 25
payroll entries we actually use
analytics between the trainees outliers
things like that which I think expect
assurance and help suspects risk rather
than just doing testing we're just
getting a highlight out so that the
several reports that come out of that
that's in the next section on
independence just highlights to you that
we don't provide any of the services of
the financial status to the council and
it highlights to you the feed for the
audits and it highlights as we've noted
there that there are likely to be some
changes to the fee from the plan to feed
as we haven't yet concluded the audit we
have not yet quantified data but once we
have finished the audit we will
basically break those areas down the
bank may only with an hour an analysis
of those and then bring that back to
this committee and then also any
variation from the local public sector
or two appointments kidnapped from
detection through or before Appendix A
just sex over the communications we have
you to be really clear tape and then
pennies be bubbly fun for us quiz to
take you through again you have an
updated version of Appendix B circulated
separate to you in for
yes so intended to be you know isn't it
changed if I go down the left side which
gives the areas of cows that with it
yeah and then the actions to resolve to
check out the state the states of the
audit and Leon rat and Sanders who is
resolving these so the water have
changed are on cash flow where that is
ready for Malaysia Malaysia partner
review now so since we've found to clear
that those work through the review
process on Kashyap Bank we're still
waiting for the clarification of with a
ploy investment balance and I've had the
new nano second one over six movies
before the voyages and HS asking why I
management food to come to conclusion on
the issue next is to do with the
pensions work so that's now ready for
find your partner review terms of the
work that would be completed and that's
the same for collection fun so being
completed and is ready for our payroll
the the variances that we have the
monthly variances those of difference
between expectations and what's there
the actual monies virtual mouths that be
processed by the payroll of those
various still being looked at by the
finance team so that's between ourselves
and
and that creditors are creditors we just
have some testing to finish there in
terms of making sure these monies are in
the correct year so we'll conclude on
that page okay so then we have reserved
as we still have some previous with
reserves yes sir on reserves sorry if I
take these resources there's a couple of
grants received in advance just in
progress that we we may have resolved
finally tonight I'll have a look at
tomorrow morning and then related
parties and journals have been ready
imagine part three review as well and
that leaves the remaining four closing
procedures that we have on all audits -
to do - just go through my partner and
minor review is being completed
okay any questions
Oh God I think you pretty mention those
today so I just want a bit of
clarification like them with regard to
the post down reports at the end of the
year but you did say it seems to happen
every year is it a particular problem
and in the public sector that it's not
easy to close down on when they close
down so it does happen sometimes it
isn't running tained
it does create a problem in terms of all
the evidence because we haven't gotten
the report that's actually used to kind
of reduce the accounts and that is quite
common with a lot of the systems that
authorities use it have calmed across a
number of clients so it's a case of make
remember in this part you closed down
procedures that you need to retain that
that report I'm not sure better
difference isn't the invalid just
clarify that does that mean that these
only live in the sense that we would
only enter data on it or can date to be
8 put on there from external
organizations our system so be our staff
there's a few other systems I'm not
stupid question I just move carefully
yeah so it's just a question that once
we know that they've stopped entering on
the lord's day of the year that we
actually run the reports off to the loss
yeah I think now is the is the rep's of
bed system and reports have numbers mmm
but they have various and there's
various detail under that same number
and so it's just making sure that we're
running those additional
so we write the scripts but it is you
can want a summary report you can write
a detailed report you can run it by
community of use you can run it by
current year and it's just making sure
that we've got the right plantation set
into the systems around and that's where
some of the issue as well just making
sure we've run so I should be cleared up
food so that is sort of more like two
main types of ends to make sure that
we've got it so schedule Jail in the way
we're noting down the reports that were
being asked for to make sure that we get
number one next you can set the table
thank you Jim no conscious task as far
as the sort of like clarification of the
accounts is concerned is there a
resource issue behind that and if so why
yes there has been a resource issue this
year
I think it's worth noting that he
doesn't just be the ey that's being
backed by that has been or one of the
firm's that do local authorities and so
sixty percent of local authority
opinions were issued by the 30s to July
this year support two percent obviously
were and as I said that's fairly common
picture and percentage across the Thames
I know it's sort of fairly indicative of
our percentages the issue that can only
talk about issues about what I know -
let's call it in other firms it's a
number of different factors so obviously
the very tight deadlines so we have two
months to do it we used to have one this
very tough day in December then for a
long time a deadline was the end
first time last year was the end of end
of July when we did achieve I think a
very high percentage action last year as
a firm this year we have more audit
clients as a result of the PSA we
tendering so we've got a lot of new
audit clients we also had electrician
and we expected a higher levels of
sickness so we had quite a number of I
would say quite experienced people left
us whether that was because of the
experience last year I don't know but
last year was certainly very difficult
in terms of delivering all of our audit
work or trying to deliver it all within
that two month period there for example
there was an 80 July so I think some
people just took the decision that there
were other things that they could do so
we lost quite a lot of experience stuff
and it takes a long time to try to
recruit additional experienced staff and
even if you get somebody through them
you know four people got three months
notice period even then when you get
them through the door you need to get
them up to date on our systems you need
to get some update date on public sector
within our public sector auditors so we
had a trician and we weren't able to
fill those gaps because we would apply
to me like I said we also have sickness
that news I think there's backward does
that indicate bigger pictures or bigger
issues so there's an issue with the
sustainability of the 31st of July
deadline deadline for the accounts to be
published but that is often viewed as
kind of when the only needs to be done
and I think there is a mature
sustainability issue with that because
we keep them frozen for burial expenses
that you receive with good quality or
debt because it's giving you assurance
on your
statement so if we don't feel that we've
got the right people to do an audience
have enough people with the right skills
we'll have to come back when we can put
the right team in to do the altie work
and those were the decisions we had to
make this year we made them I think
quite as early as we could in hindsight
we probably could have made them even
earlier but I think we did make the
decisions and we did call that out at
the appointment we recognized that if
all the trans Jew is not deliverable we
recognize its presented a lot of
challenges for a finance team and that's
why I've sort of recognized that Harriet
bad with us because we know the impact
the ugly dragging on has on the other
things that they're trying to do with
bed running the council in
forward-looking so hopefully that
answers your question I think the other
thing I have I mentioned I guess it's
just these tracks the attractiveness of
public sector have already turned all it
generally has also meant it's been quite
difficult to attract and replace there's
people that we lost my just carry on is
their action plans who actually sort of
bring forward the the accounts next year
because I'm gonna be we've still got
items outstanding here we are in
December so is there an action plan is
are there plans to actually improve the
situation is eat if not completely
situation we experienced accounts yeah
so senior so experienced I what we call
them graduates and manager level and so
one of those initiatives that we did we
went out second Africa and I think
across the firms they're not just
probably effective a court because we
use mix teams and Saudis we've recruited
250 experienced always to South Africa
should be joining us in January or
February so significant focus on that
and kind of keeping that recruitment
pipeline open and a training being on it
so where we can do executive experience
people that's not always possible we're
also planning at the moment for our
scheduling for next year and we have a
discussion with Naomi and Harriet before
to say we we recognize that next year
because we're behind and we probably
won't be able to do all of our all is by
the end of July the key thing is that we
have an agreed plan upfront which means
that we come in for us short people
short period with a good team so be
there four or five weeks as opposed to
this year where it's kind of dragged on
so the thing is we we haven't yet agreed
those days but the key thing is that we
agreed dates that we converted the
comfortable with and that we can deliver
to that may be May June July August or
September we haven't yet gone through
that process but we know we won't be
able to deliver all of our audits by the
end of July because we have a lot of
catch-up to do and the pointer nation
before just about the sustainability of
such a significant I think okay thank
you very much Chancellor Perry thank you
having listened to a number of these all
your reports over the years from my
point of view I thought it was
encouraging that you report it well on
the transition period because there's a
bit of an old hand we have expressed
concerns in the past with some of the
comments that auditors at made and I
think from my point of view this is
probably one of the most positive
reports I've heard in in a couple of
years I don't know why other people
think that I think the way it's been the
finance team is operated and the reports
that we've got from yourselves and it's
far more positive and less areas of
concern being expressed and we've been
either previously thank you
any further questions Jana don't the
company loves them but about Terry here
is great question we've got said the
section 106 money held on behalf of the
NHS
who does who dips that from they on KPMG
for weeks that was almost worried about
me but really they're not in their
account you know the vision yes this is
like I don't know we don't know if it's
the right amount to me I can't either
if he's not been checked well we know
the value we know the value in the
account but we don't know what the value
if it's there a correct value in the
account is all about this mic so I just
wanted to make sure it was tortured in
some way yeah the last one was the paper
being turned around on it now it's to do
with a very firm money al can be very
easily on page six point two nine tries
to do with the asset delivery program
which is the risk area at the bottom of
what are our findings you have we will
monitor progress during 2019-20 as the
core business case develops what form
does the moisture take does it just by
using as the monetary when you come in
to do the probably over five weeks so
essentially just checked those to get
regular updates on programs
it concerns about it so we do keep an
eye I think but we don't have detailed
audit work the audit work would be done
in relation to value for money
conclusion which we to be honest can do
at any point between sort of February
and when we conclude the Nordics for now
but we normally try and do it roundabout
large so we catch a little here
thank you any further questions
did you did you want to speak so we've
got some recommendations here do you
want me to read them out individually
number one that the contents of the
draft audit results before to be noted
number two that the financial statements
will be improved in principle number
three that the final sign-off of the
financial statements be delegated to the
chairman of the Audit Committee subject
to no significant audit changes being
identified post the committee meeting we
just clarify because I think significant
come in lots of different things than
many different people and should the
word be material in relation to your to
the financial aspect or it should have
to be also refer to any changes in the
or vehicle I think what's interesting is
is then ties back to our they also make
most interesting in relation to that one
that I was fine a sign up of the letter
patient as well which includes an audit
results report as well as the sign for
the accountants alongside the accounts
we need electronic representation and
that has to be signed on the same day as
yourselves to NCM not signed by yourself
as a chain yes apologies that should be
whole person recommendation but if we
can just minute that that's the case
okay yes so check your significant
material and down good luck can I make a
suggestion on that chairman could we say
significant and material because it
could be material but not very not
really very significant I think what we
do significant v's material but this is
where my problem but significant comes
in that's got meaning and substance in
its validated in the audio for in terms
and what we mean by lap times and if
there are any any other significant
material changes then we'd called
another alder meeting yeah apologies
chair I didn't take the committee
through the management lack of
representation last which was included
in appendix c of our reports about
certain standard effects that we could
always require representation on there's
nothing unusual within them
so are we happy with that with them
changing significant to material yeah
and ID number thought that the movement
in general fund balances be noted
yes we yes yes it's the material all
these changes been identified and the
letter of representation being signed
because they have to be signed on the
same day so yes okay yeah happy with
that 8:15 I'm close the meeting and I'll
about what I would like to do is I'd
like to say thank you to everybody but
particularly to our finance team because
I know they have worked very very hard
and I have done a little bit of ear
bashing so thank you thank you very much
we really appreciate the hard work your
team anything really
thank you very late